the winner of RuPaul's Drag Race
America's next drag superstar is
[Music]
after weeks of fierce lease ashamed
RuPaul's Drag Race crowned its season 11
winner
follow your oddities and acquire freak
fried Eevee took the crown and a
$100,000 prize after an epic lip-sync
battle against runner up Brooklyn
Heights - Lady Gaga's edge of glory
[Music]
I'm a winner Cara Delevingne
and girlfriend Ashley Benson were among
us some of the famous faces rooting on
the Queens from the audience and Evie's
drag race co-stars agreed she would take
the crown I'm team weirdo miss team Evie
oddly you know all the girls are really
amazing I think they all deserve to be
in the top but one of the girls that
I've always really loved watching it's
easy oddly I think sure her drag is
fresh it's young its creative and it
really kind of just pushes the
boundaries half the time I look at her
[ __ ] and I'm like girl this is trash
like what are you doing and then it
comes out to be the most amazing thing
so I think she really has a great shot
he caught up with the season 11
showstopper ahead of her big win at drag
con la 20 19 where she opened up about
what it would mean to her to win it all
it'd be really validating because a lot
of what I do and what my art stands for
isn't necessarily about perfection and
polish and I feel like it would really
show not only the kids but more
importantly show me that you don't need
to always have the best connections the
most money like you just need to have a
really strong clear point of view and be
authentic to who you are it was really
dope yeah it was just it was a dream
come true
wish I could have done better wish I was
perfect all that but I'm glad I'm glad I
was able to show that I'm not I guess
you